we can't imagine what it's like as
westerners to live in a country where
every aspect of your life has to be run
through a politically correct filter
people here complain about wilkism where
they hate Trump and we can sit here and
talk about how much we hate Trump or
hate woke is and whatever and there's no
consequences but to live in a country
where even your friends are turning and
spying on you and you have to watch what
you say and at work everything's in this
context and every movie every song every
TV show every newspaper how it
encompasses and affects you we can't
wrap our heads around it
Michael malice welcome to the show I'm
so nervous why kidding idiot is it is it
because of all of the cameras and lights
yeah yes I'll be gentle with you I don't
want gentlemen yeah I've heard that
so uh you were about to have an argument
with me are you planned to have a
potential argument no no I had an
imaginary argument okay so do you ever
get imaginary arguments with your
friends oh yeah I fantasize about them
all the time right yeah yeah
so this was the imaginary argument
I've been working on this book as long
as we've been friends
uh two and a half years as you would say
and you texted me over the weekend about
Louis Ling right and he's chapter two
and I'm like this [ __ ] can I curse curse
away this Brit this bloody worst word
that you could have used this well I
could have called you an Irishman yeah
this bloody Brit has had all this time
to read this book He's not going to have
it done for the interview he's just
gonna talk about it cursorally when he
knows how much I worked on it and how
much it meant to me and how much I
wanted to hear his perspective as an
Englishman because uh lady Thatcher is
on the cover and she's a main figure in
the book and I was all prepared to come
in huffing and Puffin and I'm afraid
Chris did his homework I'm afraid that
there's nothing for you to huff and puff
about so that was true that was
resurfaced by read wise which is a
highlighting oh okay so it had given it
back to me because it's a relatively new
recent highlight now the Lewis Ling
thing it turns out I actually did miss
him because he was on the front cover of
a previous book
so I maybe I have missed him once
already but my head is in a little bit
of a spin uh because
for all that everybody that's smart
seems to talk about the Soviet Union and
lessons that come out of Communism and
stuff you know lots of people the Lexus
and the Petersons of the world or
whatever seem to draw a lot of lessons
from this
I frankly didn't know much about it like
if you'd held a gun to my head and said
tell me when the Berlin Wall fell or
tell me who the main characters were in
the decline of Communism between the UK
America and and the Soviet Union I
wouldn't have known uh so it has been a
little bit like a I don't know like a
fast track education through
some pretty brutal elements of History
I didn't know it either you know when I
sat down to write this I didn't know any
of it um I didn't know why it was such a
big deal that the Berlin Wall fell and
what that meant I knew in a you know I
was born in the Soviet Union but I left
when I was like one and a half so
obviously I don't remember it in any
sense and though you know we were raised
in my household with kind of Soviet
inspired values for lack of a better
term I still had no good idea of what it
meant when it fell how bad it was what
are the lessons none of that and I still
don't have a good answer as to why the
Cold War which was the absolute primary
foreign policy concern for over half a
century for the West is like forgotten
it it I don't I know how to reconcile
those two things because starting from
you know very quickly after the end of
World War II up through 91 all foreign
policy whether in Britain Germany West
Germany the U.S this was the filter this
was the big concern is this person how
is this person going to address the Cold
War if you're talking about a prime
minister or Chancellor or a president
and
if you ask people who Brezhnev is right
who ran the Soviet Union for close to 20
years what percent of educated well-read
people now people who are a little older
than us will know know who he is it's
it's a tiny percentage and
so when writing this I still don't have
an understanding as to why it kind of
fell on my shoulders because this isn't
some hipster band that you probably
haven't heard of
this was the Cold War and yet now if you
talk about it they're like oh yeah
wasn't that on like Labrador records
history type thing yeah and it's like
this is millions of people in many
countries over decades suffering things
that all of us listening to this and
everyone listening to this is in at
least a semi-free country would find
unimaginable just the just even the one
aspect of the idea of knowing that
whenever you're on the phone it's tapped
how that would affect your phone calls
knowing now you know we have that here
in the sense of the NSA but not to the
extent where like if I'm texting you and
I'm making a joke about Trump or Biden I
have to what worry not knock at the door
in the middle of the night or am I gonna
get fired am I just gonna get upset and
be sat down by you know the authorities
and be like what did this email mean how
do you know Chris who else have you
talked about these things with Chris and
have no I can't complain to anyone
because if I'm complaining I'm only
going to make it worse we can't wrap our
heads around with that kind of lifestyle
is like and this was the norm for a lot
of people and that's even the like the
easiest part to deal with you know you
just don't talk politics but the rest of
it you know it's just was so pervasive
and extensive and for so long and for so
many people
and I I don't understand how this you
know the New York Times says the 1619
project which focuses on things which we
can all agree are a major historic
concern you know the slave trade you
know is obviously a you know a
historical Abomination uh so the subject
matter at least is important even if
there's spin on it you know is a certain
skew but this is something that's just
not discussed and I I I can't I don't
even have a hypothesis as to I know I do
have a hypothesis the hypothesis is
there's not an easy narrative right I
had to find this narrative it's not an
easy story of you know it's it's okay
they're the bad guys but then why are we
teaming up with them in World War II and
who are the good guys are they Reagan
but is it really Reagan and Thatcher
because you know they weren't entirely
the heroes in the eyes of the press so
when you don't have like the Vietnam war
is another or the Korean war is called
The Forgotten War because it was a
stalemate right so since there's no
narrative and you can't make it into
Hollywood where it's like good wins over
evil they just stop talking about it and
when you stop talking about it you're
ignoring what happened to Untold numbers
of men women and children who had to
suffer needlessly and who are now being
forgotten and I'm like I'm gonna do
something about that the complexity of
the truth is inconvenient for both sides
yes yes yes yeah yeah
um so I'm gonna try and do my best to
summarize
what I think is the reason or the
message behind the book because a good
bit of it is um
repeatedly being stamped in the face by
these very very uncomfortable brutal
situations that many people across
Romania Ukraine but largely in the
Soviet Union Russia especially is
that they're dealing with
but it's a book That's supposed to be
about good as well right it's about Good
and Evil and it kind of does take a
little while from it took a while for me
to get to the stage where I was like oh
I I kind of understand here it seems to
me that you have an issue with cynicism
um
being used and weaponized as a reason
for people to not have hope
what you have done is displayed some of
the most egregious transgressions of
humanity from recent history very
recently you know this is this isn't
World War one this is since World War
One almost exclusively since World War
one yeah 1917 right yes yes
so
you've tried to put out front this is
how depraved and awful and disgusting
human existence can become
and yet it didn't win yes and yet people
said that it would never be defeated and
yet it happened essentially overnight
from everything to nothing in the space
of no time at all which means that when
we are facing struggles in future
that degree of Hope
should be something that should be
continued forward given that life right
now is not as bad as it was then so the
Delta between where we wanted to be and
where it is isn't as big to leap
how far am I off I think you said it
better than I could have I would not
change one word of that other than maybe
Delta because people don't get that
reference uh and I'm being only a little
glib I think you articulated it
perfectly in in one case it was
literally overnight
um uh when helmet Cole who was the
chancellor or of West Germany he's in
Poland with like valessa and you know
telling this it's just this is a very um
uh emotional
um book for me because
when you see the photos of these people
and their kids and you know there were
times when the people in charge were
ready to start shooting them and someone
else was like we're not shooting them
and you see these children it's just
like you know it's like hear these
stories of like I think with Seth
MacFarlane who had a ticket on 9 11 and
he like missed this flight and he has I
think that ticket framed in his house
like a plane ticket it's just like you
know it's just terrifying when you
realize this wasn't hypothetical tianmen
square was June 4th 1989. so that year
1989 when shit's hitting the fan you
know East Germany they're like we want
another Tiananmen Square and they put
the guns in the hands of the military
they gave them the bullets they were
ready
um so you had helmet coal in Poland with
Lake Walesa who was the head of
solidarity and kind of the main figure
in liberating Poland from communist Rule
and Le qualessa says to him you know I
don't think the Berlin Wall is going to
be around much longer I think it's going
to be like a matter of a a of some a few
months
and how Nicole laughs in his face he
laughs in his face like valessa was I
believe 46 Hamilton I think was 60 or
something about that and he goes look
you're young
you don't understand how these things
work they take a long time it was like
patting him on the head the head had
fallen
and it fell the next day the Berlin Wall
the next day and like and El Nicole
literally says there were so many quotes
in this that I found that I was just
like I like I kept if this was in a
movie it would be ridiculous writing and
how Nicole says I'm at the wrong party
and it gets on a plane and gets his ass
out of Poland and what else is just
great with the fall of the Berlin Wall I
know we're spoiling to the good parts is
no one even bothered to call Gorbachev
right so you know East Germany is
heavily backed by the Soviet Union it
was kind of a Soviet satellite state it
was part of the Warsaw act which is
basically the counterweight to Nato all
these countries agreed to have mutual
defense
and Gorbachev wakes up
you know in Moscow and there's people
dancing on top of the Berlin wall and no
one bothered to call him or let him know
and you can only imagine what's going on
in his head you know it's just seeing
that but it was the same thing that was
going on the head of people all over the
world because the Berlin Wall for so
long was you know imprisoning half of a
city or three or you know uh three
quarters of a city in a sense uh people
were shot children were killed in prison
for trying to cross it uh and then you
know they're just drunk and Blasting
their stereos you know to have this
thing literally overnight go from a
symbol of
imprisonment torture oppression to the
biggest party on Earth
is something that I think even now it's
hard for us to wrap our heads around
going back to the cynicism thing why do
you think it is that it's so prevalent
because it's something that both of us I
think rail against both of us have a
particular distaste for people that are
um unreasonably cynical and it's you
know part of the reason that I ended up
moving countries in an attempt to try
and be around people who are left less
cynical what is it that's so alluring
about that cynical mindset
I I don't I don't know what I hate more
than cynicism you know maybe like you
know literal totalitarianism but in
terms of personality I don't know what I
hate more and what I'm more against
because
it's such an absurd
premise that's so easily disprovable uh
cynicism as I understand it not in the
you know uh uh you know Greek
philosophical sense but this idea that
like
everything sucks
or you know don't get your hopes up it's
not going to work out as long as you
have one counter example the thesis is
disproven
and you're telling me that like and like
if people are like um uh
uh you know I agree that most comedians
suck
I agree that most movies suck I agree
that most books suck I agree that most
podcasts suck especially mine
none of them not one there's no book
that you read that you're a better
person having read it there's no movie
you've seen where you're like holy crap
I feel like I'm watching something from
Heaven there's no song that you've ever
heard that even when you hear it for the
20th time it shakes your soul none and
if you're that kind of person
that's on you that means you are somehow
guarded or damaged or something within
uh and I think there is an enormous
amount of pressure
uh and from what you and I have talked
about it's I guess more prevalent in
British culture than America but there
is a lot of pressure of you know kind of
just head down go to the factory do the
work don't hope for anything better and
it's just like
you don't have to become
a king or a president or a CEO to
improve right not everyone has to be a
fitness model to be in better shape
right if you're someone who's 400 pounds
you can get down to 250 you're still a
big dude but think how much Healthy You
Are your clothes Mobility walking up the
stairs quality of life in every way is
that such an unreasonable goal but for a
cynic it's like what's the point you're
still fat well yeah you are but come on
these are extremely different qualities
of life so I think it is a very
non-rational
um emotional
perspective that tries to present itself
as it's as if it's realistic and
cool-headed it's like oh you're naive
you're you're a Pollyanna and like you
pointed out the point this book is
I'm not being hopeful in the sense of
nothing bad happens I'm not being
hopeful in the sense of the bad guys
aren't really that bad the extent of the
depravity in you know I I was on my
buddy uh Dave Smith he's a very failed
comedian in his podcast and he goes if
you read 90 of this book you think it's
the black pill correct because you're
reading it and you're like that's what I
mean I'm like okay chapter 10 it was
still not here and you're you're like I
just one you know example off the top of
my head I hope I get through with that
my voice breaking because I still
read it and just it just haunts me to my
core you know early in the 1920s there
are these children who were like
homeless in Moscow and they were like
thieves pickpockets you know your kid
living on the streets you gotta make do
so the Checker come the secret police
round them up and they take them to the
cellar of the prison and they start
beating them and torturing them and
making them who who are you working with
who are your uh colleagues whatever the
term they used right in your gang they
don't they're kids they don't so they
take them in the car and they drive
around they go point out who you're and
at that point you're like yeah him him
you know anyone and then they took them
back and they kept beating them and you
hear the other prisoners like the adults
hearing these kids these kids screaming
and these adult criminals are like they
were losing their minds just hearing the
screens the children as the children
realized they're being returned to the
seller so when you hear about the so
there's no whitewashing in this book of
how bad it gets you know know but people
have this idea that like there's no
point in fighting because you know it's
inevitable that the bad guys are going
to win but they haven't you know like
I'm here if Hitler had his way I'd be
dead if Hitler had his way you'd be dead
right like you know Britain was standing
alone against Hitler for quite a while
uh or you'd be a slave I don't know what
you'd be whatever point being you know
this insistence that villainy always why
is it you know this is the line I had
you know one thing about this book why
is it that the bad guys always get what
they want well I can't get what I want
once and when you put in those terms
it's like yeah you're right and even if
I can't what I'm just going to be like
ah too bad so I I don't think it's a
coherent
um worldview I think it's a very
emotional response coached in the mask
of rationality and realism and I don't
think it's realistic at all
it's able to give people it's a much
more
um sort of pedestalized position to be
in right if you say that everything's
going to be bad it's it feels like a
well researched the critic always feels
like the guy that's well researched yeah
right right as opposed to the person
that's hopeful because the person that's
hopeful that things don't happen have
and maybe this is actually reflected in
terms of our neurochemistry Andrew human
taught me about this thing where if you
tell someone that a movie is going to be
really really good that dopamine release
even if it's as good as they expect it
to be is less and if the movie is less
good than they expected it to be then
they lose even more sure so what you're
doing is by being the cynic you're
saving yourself from ever being the
person that over promises so maybe
reality does deliver the world better
than you'd hoped well brilliant that's a
bonus for you and oh well you know I'm
just trying to keep everybody's feet on
the ground that seems like a noble cause
right so you named
each of the different chapter most of
the chapters up until toward the end
after this famous iron Rand speech or
passage from a speech that she gave why
what's so special to you about that
particular speech
um
so there's a there's a um in Prague
there's a a museum of Communism and I
visited went there when I was in Prague
several years ago and I remembered the
captions on the different exhibits were
worded in a very kind of
idiosyncratic way because in a western
Museum
um you would have it be kind of
scholarly you know even the Holocaust
Museum it's going to be kind of this is
what it is yeah yeah very kind of
emotionless matter of fact and I
remember that in this Museum of
communism because you know the Czechs
were under the boot of the Soviet Union
for many decades it's like according to
you know this ideology we would all have
food but in reality thanks to their
demented this demented reality we were
all starving and there was one caption
they talk about how you know how like on
the side of a pack of cigarettes it says
you know smoking this will be dangerous
to your health well in the same way
living in communist country would be
dangerous to your health so it's it it
was very much like this kind of Fu and I
set my my protege tray was in progress
and they go can you I guess I'm like I I
don't can you give take me photos of
captions and he went through to send
them all and this was you know over this
past summer and
it that it was really a gut punch and
this is after the book was largely done
because that was the first moment when I
realized to what extent
it encompasses every aspect of
the people living in these countries
lives you know think we can't imagine
what it's like as westerners to live in
a country where every aspect of your
life has to be run through a politically
correct filter now people here complain
about wilkism or they hate Trump but you
can go to the sports game you can watch
some Shoot Em Up movie you know Jerry
Bruckheimer movie or something stupid
you could watch How I Met Your Mother
there's something political about it
it's just but and we can sit here and
talk about how much we hate Trump or
hate Wilkins and whatever and there's no
consequences but to live in a country
where even your friends are they are
turning and spying on you and you have
to watch what you say and at work
everything's in this context and every
movie every song every TV show every
newspaper how it encompasses and affects
you it's we can't wrap our heads around
it and you know so Rand was testifying
in 1947 in front of the house on
American Activities Committee and she
was the only
person testifying the only witness who
had lived in the Soviet in what became
the Soviet Union and the Congress people
were pushing back at her
because they're because they were just
like because what she was saying to them
was Fantastical to them because they
were of this idea that like you know we
have it one way you know the Russians
have it a different way but people are
all pretty much the same all around the
world which is true you know to in to
that extent and this congressman from
Pennsylvania goes like don't they like
have picnics and visit their
mother-in-law and and you could sense
the exasperation her voice and she says
the quote which is on the back cover of
the book where she goes look it's almost
impossible to convey to a free people
what it's like to live in a totalitarian
dictatorship she's like I can give you a
little a lot of details I can never
completely convince you because you're
free and she breaks down like just try
to imagine you're in constant Terror
from morning till night and at night
you're waiting for the doorbell to ring
where you live in a country where human
life means nothing less than nothing and
you know it where you don't know who's
gonna do what to you when because
there's no rights or law of any kind and
this sense
uh which I grew up with to some extent
it was kind of passively fed into me
you've told me about
uh what's that concern that you have you
sometimes worry about giving people
pieces of information because how can
you be used against you yeah you run the
filter in your head like the sense of
never being entirely safe
is something that I don't think
Americans
thank God can wrap their heads around
because they think I think in so far
emotionally you can kind of get to the
point where you know you go to school
and they're teaching you lies and the
newspapers are full lies and then the
movies are full of propaganda so we
could kind of get to that but in the
sense of like there's nowhere else to go
we can't really appreciate what that's
like so that kind of was the theme you
know trying my best and again I also
can't I've been to North Korea but it's
one thing to beautiful country wouldn't
want to live there it's uh it's one
thing to visit because I knew I could
get my ass out right it's another thing
to be like this is the entirety of My
reality from the day I'm born till the
day I'm gonna die and there's no
alternative to this and you know just
how pervasive that is I don't think any
of us know what that's like to have a
life that is effectively without Choice
our entire lives it's the difference
between being homeless or going camping
yeah yeah but you know even with
homelessness it's what if you're
homeless and everyone else is homeless
that I mean that's the difference
because when you're homeless you had you
used to have a home you could still have
a shelter you know there's ways to
change your environment but yeah I think
that's a good way of putting it given
the atrocities that occurred throughout
all of the 1900s under communism how the
[ __ ] did people not foresee
the issues that were going to occur
um
well is it only obvious in retrospect
I I
think
that's a great question how did they not
foresee I think a lot of people did
foresee it uh Mikhail bakunan who was
Marx's big rival uh he had an essay from
1867 which is in the anarchist handbook
and he just dissects Marxism and you
read it and you're like this guy not
only predicted the Soviet Union he
predicted the problems of the Soviet
Union prophetic very prophetic and the
quote that if I could sum it up in one
sentence it's his quote where he says uh
if the people are being beaten by a
stick they're not much more mollified if
it's called the people stick
so when you have the and even if you the
argument was this is going to be
temporary right we're going to have this
kind of oppressive dictatorship the
proletariat we're going to purge these
evil elements from our society and once
that's done and everyone's working for
the sake of everybody else
um and the parasites are kind of
destroyed you know everyone's gonna
you're not going to be you know like my
hard work is not going to be going
towards you know Carnegie and having an
eighth Mansion for him it's going to be
going towards the people I'm going to
work less
um there is a kind of coherence to it in
the course of time these methods will be
abolished when they've become
unnecessary yeah yeah and you know Emma
Goldman who's on the cover she sat down
with Lenin and she's like you know
because the Socialist argument was under
capitalism you're free to starve right
but under socialism the individual will
be allowed to flourish so she sits down
with him and she goes people are getting
locked up for their political views
there's no free speech like this is not
what we're about and Lenin goes this is
like a like a Bourgeois privilege like
we're we're in a Time Revolution once
this kind of civil Russian Civil War
settled then we're going to be being
reintroducing freedoms and it was a
complete lie once the Russian Civil War
as she saw personally was stopped then
they just doubled down even more and
even Lenin's erstwhile colleagues from
other like the anarchists the uh the
mensheviks they were all locked up and
when Lenin adopted their views the
menshevik views and the menshevik
started pointing out goes if you point
this out that is being counted
revolutionary you're going to go to jail
so even pointing out the hypocrisy
became a felony
um so you know yeah very quickly it
became clear what this means in practice
and God bless her and her partner in
crime literal crime Alexander Berkman
they fled the Soviet Union
um very early on they went to the West
they said guys this is a complete
nightmare these are people are not
helping the workers they're like we're
for violence we're not like pansies here
I try to kill Frick we're for bloody
Revolution we're forced stealing food if
you're starving you're not but but this
is not what we're about there they're
oppressing the the say exact people
we're supposedly for and the Western
intellectuals who love have and other
people do the dirty work we're like oh
you don't get it or like uh it's fine so
that kind of
to me it was very disturbing and this is
something that happens to this day when
you have these eyewitnesses
you know speak their truth and testify
as to what they saw and you have someone
who went to Harvard be like oh you don't
get it read a book
talking about anarchists especially in
the U.S what was the story of lewisling
oh God loose link story I love him he's
such a badass
um Lewis Ling was one of seven men there
was a um
uh in um I forget the year in the late
1800s there was a rally
in Haymarket Square in Chicago
um this is when they were after the
Civil War had ended they thought there
was going to be a third American
Revolution yeah the first one which
overthrew aristocracy and monarchy the
second which overthrew slavery and now
you're gonna have one which is going
over through the capitalists and we're
gonna have you know a revolution here in
America and have things like the eight
hour day and you know abolish profit and
all that other stuff that that they
liked and there was a uh um uh meeting a
public meeting there were some speeches
very it was peaceful not mostly peaceful
it's entirely peaceful the mayor came
stuck her right no problem here he
leaves someone throws a bomb we still
don't know to this day who threw that
bomb for what purpose a lot of cops were
killed a lot of the cops started
shooting a lot of people were killed uh
they arrested seven people and they put
them on various anarchists some who
weren't even there
um some who had spoken there and
advocated peace and they put them on
trial is basically like you preach this
ideology and they charged them with
murder uh even though there was not even
an allegation that they had thrown the
bomb or encouraged it or were like yeah
more you know Lewis Ling they searched
his house and they found bombs at his
house and his attorney said well uh my
client has the right to have bombs in
his house and which became this kind of
meme before memes were a thing where
it's like uh uh he's ascribed to have
said I couldn't have thrown that bomb I
was at home making mobs and they
imprisoned him and someone's we still
don't know how snuck a blasting capsule
into his jail and rather than be hanged
he detonated his jaw and he was if you
look at photos Lewis Ling it's it's like
a time traveler because he looks like
Channing Tatum or something he looks
like he came out of Abercrombie had I
think abercrombie's not doing like the
studs anymore but whatever like it would
never cover this thing and he blows off
his jaw it's hanging and with his blood
he writes in the wall hooray for Anarchy
uh and he dies the next day he's like
they're not gonna get to me so he was
you know people uh ignorantly
romanticized Che Guevara uh but he was
the first really it's like young Spirit
of violent Defiance and I mean violent
in every sense the word
um and he really was a you know people
the the cop who arrested him uh wrote a
book about it and even he talked about
how people came to visit him in jail
because they were so impressed by his
like magnificent Physique in what a
study was so he really was a total
badass you know he certainly not a good
guy but certainly uh in terms of
literature this kind of a very
um a specific archetypical figure what
happened to the other six oh they were
hanged uh one uh no no no one apologize
sorry they were told if you write for
clemency uh the governor will lessen the
charges and some they're like I'm not I
didn't do anything I didn't kill I
didn't kill anyone I'm not for murder
I'm not asking for clemency and they're
like all right and in fact one of them
as he went to The Gallows turns and says
can I address the crowd and say a few
words and they just killed him right
then and there so they began there's a
they got pardoned posthumously uh there
is a monument to there to them in a
cemetery near Chicago Emma Goldman's was
repatriated to be buried there as well
that dates on her tombstone are wrong
which is funny and the quote for August
fees quote
is worded several different ways but one
of them they're all effectively
technically the same meaning uh someday
the voices someday our voice someday our
voices will speak louder than those you
strangle today uh and it's true
how would you describe the
Vibe of political philosophy at the
start of the 20th century because
everything kind of comes out of this
right we're talking about anarchism
around that sort of a time we're about
to have the first world war we're about
to have the Inception of the Soviet
Union we're about to have this sort of
onset of Communism and then Downstream
from that everything else happening
what was unique about that period in
terms of political philosophy history
that enabled this uh mix of ingredients
to start cooking I think a big part of
it was the rise of the intellectual
because you had the Industrial
Revolution happening kind of in that
window and as a result of this there was
a lot more money going around and there
was a lot more opportunity for people to
make their living just being
intellectuals and intellectuals had a
much higher
um status in that Society they became an
emerging class
um so and also you have these enormous
fortunes being generated as a result of
industrialization becoming a thing
Farmers you know were kind of on the
down and instead you had people building
factories and these giant kind of
conglomerates that were changing the
face of the world and you had reactions
to this you know progressivism of course
being one of them in America
um you know this kind of Classical
liberalism was falling by the wayside
because the argument was not
unreasonably I think you had these
enormous amounts of immigrants coming to
the states uh from Europe and Eastern
Europe and from Ireland and Italy and
they're living in these horrifying
conditions they don't have sanitation uh
you know the people are getting injured
at work and there's no hope for them uh
children are dying young because there's
no birth control and you have a woman
who's got no husband and 13 kids like
what's she gonna do she has to
prostitute herself right
um so you know when you have these
horrifying conditions at the same time
you have the rise of the kind of you
know monopolist class a lot of people
were like all right something's not
adding up here so like we got to figure
out how to square this circle and there
were you know different approaches to
what that would look like on the one
hand you had so what people don't
appreciate now is socialism at the time
was really this kind of blanket term
about that Society has to be managed
somehow for the greater good it didn't
mean the government runs everything
necessarily that is kind of the The
Strain that went out but anarchists
consider themselves socialist even
though they're opposed to government
entirely
um so they were kind of you know you had
in Britain you had the Fabian Society
coming up you had you know uh the webs
um and the Bolsheviks were the ones who
won and I think what ended up happening
and I don't think this particular
ambiguous is all these different
branches of intellectual leftism were
like all right we've got a shot here
this is the one country where they're
trying it we have to make it work and
give it a shot to see if it does work
and Eugene Lyons you know who is a
former comedy just I discuss them on the
book journalists said yeah you you guys
were looking at the Russians like guinea
pigs and you were perfectly happy to
have them just be ground into nothing
because this was your noble experiment
and they were the ones paying the price
but you were the ones kind of reaping
the benefits yeah that's so interesting
the fact that
even if it wasn't particularly your
brand of socialism your brand of
progressivism that you wanted even if
they weren't getting it right and the
costs that were being
that the toll was huge
if at the end of it you could have
pointed at it and said well that was a
victory that went well that would
justify your movement going forward and
in in all fairness as different times uh
moved on there were plenty of socialists
and leftists who were like all right I'm
out too much uh yeah when when Hitler
and Stalin signed the rip and drop pact
and uh you know Treaty of non-aggression
and they basically started becoming
buddies you know overnight many of these
Communist front organizations in the
west changed their names from advocating
for being against fascism to being for
peace right oh no no we got to stay out
the world or two but there were lots of
progressives hardcore progressives who
were like you're shaking like they're
like you're shaking hands with Hitler
okay that's a rat like this is not
ambiguous this is completely where we're
against I'm out of here so they still
remained you know hardcore Democratic
socialists or whatever progressives
depending on the individual but in terms
of having a love affair for the Soviet
Union that was was a big one for them to
swallow and also just other things like
the Hungarian Revolution and Prague
spring Afghanistan these were big big
problems for lots of leftists but not so
much for people like the New York Times
the Espionage Act
was is that the same thing that's still
in now is that the same basis in America
for deporting people that have been
accused of being foreign agents and
stuff like that the one that was I think
it was 19 yeah 1917. is that the same
no I don't I'm not sure that it is so
what you're referring to is after Leon
chalgas killed chalgosh killed uh
President McKinley in 1901 and Teddy
Roosevelt came in and teza Roosevelt
said you know anarchisms are the worst
people ever they're they're worse it's
worse than slavery and so on and so
forth and they basically passed the law
saying if you're an anarchist or have
certain other ideologies you can be
deported and they there was something
called the red ark where they rounded up
a bunch of uh anarchists and radicals
including Emma Goldman Alexander Berkman
and sent them uh get your ass back to
Russia with you if you love it so much
um I don't know how if that is still I'm
sure it's probably still legally
enforced because laws don't ever get
repealed but I don't know if that's the
basis for uh um if it's being used in a
contemporary terms yeah you said in 1916
keeping us out of the war was a winning
slogan by 1917 it was a crime yeah so
Woodrow Wilson very famously campaigned
on he kept us out of War right and
Woodrow Wilson was the was only this the
second uh um Democrat to be elected
president after world after the Civil
War McKinley was not McKinley excuse me
Robert Cleveland was elected into two
non-consecutive terms because the
Republican party just basically ran the
table uh and since uh Taft and Teddy
Roosevelt in 1912 split the Republican
vote Wilson snuck in but it was not at
all clear that he was going to get
reelected because the Republicans
regrouped they had Charles Evans Hughes
who was the former Governor of New York
um and Supreme Court justice as the
nominee and it's like all right it's
it's a
we got this in the bag you know what I
mean and it was I think it was like
three thousand two thousand votes in
California decided that election uh and
it went for Wilson and he got reelected
but you know this was the big argument
he kept us out of war and then a few
months later it's like well you know we
got to go to fight war in Europe which
was complete violation the Monroe
Doctrine and what America stood for
since its Inception
um and very heavily you know Wilson
introduced just like Lenin was saying to
Goldman you know free speech is kind of
this Bourgeois contrivance you can't
have it under times of War he's saying
the same thing so people who are
advocating against the draft uh people
were advocating things like that were
imprisoned including Eugene V Debs who
was the Socialist candidate for
president he locked him up and It Came
Upon Warren Harding who was inaugurated
1921 to you know I don't know if you
pardoned him or game clemency to get him
out of jail so they were imprisoning a
lot they were you know reading the mail
it was very much a totalitarian vision
and the explanation use was you know we
have to do this because otherwise it's
going to be German spies we have to
fight the Kaiser so on and so forth make
the world safer democracy but these were
just complete bracing violation of all
sorts of constitutional principles that
are regarded nowadays as sacrosanct what
are the principles that the Soviet Union
was founded on then I think 1917 anytime
what what was the fundamental philosophy
or principles that it was well there's
the de facto De Jour right so there's
what they said it was and then there's
what it was in reality so Lenin
campaigned on this concept of all power
to the Soviets so the idea is you have
these localized worker councils and the
workers you know now that they're
liberated from the shackles of
capitalistic control they're going to
sit down figure out how to run the
factory better for themselves everyone's
going to share in the wealth everyone's
going to put in their two cents from
each according to his ability so you're
stronger than I am so you're going to do
the heavy lifting maybe I'm better with
my little hands with screws you know
everyone's going to work together it's
going to work out just phenomenally
great so you have this kind of sense of
localized control
um but very quickly it became you know
letting what Lenin wanted
um and Trotsky his kind of sidekick and
you had plays like the New York Times
saying explicitly La Land is not a
dictator he's just getting his way
because he's smarter than everybody you
know so like the the most pro-lining
propaganda that even Lenin kind of would
maybe shy away from saying with a
straight face in the Soviet Union
because he did have some semblance of
humility uh in the west it was just like
this guy's come to kind of save the
world uh um from the bad guys and and we
we all whatever we can to make sure it
works you said that Lennon was widely
regarded as a lunatic yes why
well before 90 this idea that okay we're
gonna come in we're gonna overthrow
capitalism we're gonna because you know
the Marxist idea is much more radical
than what the Soviet Union even tried to
implement because the Soviet Union was
in theory it's like putting putting your
ideas to practice right so this kind of
concept of you know everything is going
to be done through the state and we're
going to change the very nature of man
that human being is infinitely
plasticine you know early on they're
talking about like okay what if kids are
raised communally right that was wild
that absolutely took what was the thing
about
um uh code on marriage the family and
guardianship it was seen as Bourgeois to
prefer your own children over others
right because because there is so what
they did correctly or logically is you
take the idea of equality
and then you just extrapolate it
everywhere you go and it's just like it
leads the consequence so here's an idea
so like let me give you a counter a
counter example that I was doing my
North Korea book your reader when
conservatives say the family is the
basic unit of society right so they do
that in North Korea meaning if you
commit a crime Christopher like the
Williamson family's on trial because the
next eight Generations or three but it's
it's a unit unit means one it's not
divisible so if the family is the unit
and someone commits a crime the family
goes on trial so they are putting that
into practice now that's not what
conservatives mean of course but when
you're talking about equality and you
mean it thoroughly it's just like why
should one child be advantaged by having
loving wealthy parents like and we have
aspects of that here which I don't know
that are they're all entirely crazy the
argument is why should I who's the heir
to like the Kardashian Fortune as a kid
have all these advantages I've never
have to work a day in my life you're
born to a mother addicted to heroin in
some you know gutter you you we're not
going to start off with the same
opportunities that's not fair and I
think there's something to that but if
they take the extreme of well why should
one kid have more love or a better
parent than another we're just going to
take the kids and raise them all
together by professionals the government
teachers are going to raise them they're
going to be trained in this not like
look every mom and dad's winging it
that's not fair to those kids we need to
have professionals and experts raising
them and don't worry the Mom after work
can go visit her kid if she chooses this
was the the model for their whole
country and some of it they had enormous
pushback and some of it they implemented
but the whole point is
this is a new scientific Society you
guys are old fatty duddies you're doing
things just because your grandma did a
certain way we're starting from scratch
and we're rebuilding it nice and clean
along scientific principles none of this
emotionalism this kind of Bourgeois
sentimental like oh I love my kid no no
no no no no this kid doesn't belong to
you this kid belongs to everyone so it's
it doesn't it's really once you put it
into practice uh you know in North Korea
is another example like in construction
like the women have to do the
construction also because women and
women are equal so they're putting into
practice and it's just like okay good
luck with that is this a warning for
what happens if you take scientism or
rationality too far
um I don't think so because I don't
think it's really rational because I I
think that does it think that it's
rational it does but I think everything
thinks it's rational right other
Nietzsche right so this I the issue is
thinking you're more informed than you
are and not having this kind of not
understanding the limits or the bounds
of your own understanding of competence
so this kind of love of a mother for her
child isn't just like a custom or
tradition it's my understanding that
when a child is born both the parents
have this biochemical reaction towards
seeing these kids we even see with like
seagulls right if seagulls are raised
without their mom they can imprint on
like a sock with a seagull face and that
feeds the kid but there is this kind of
literal brain connection between the two
uh they did CAT scans on dogs right and
dogs the parts of the brain light up
when they see you their owners as other
as members of a pack uh so there is that
thing it kind of that's happening in
their head so as we spoke earlier about
cynicism when you have this
scientific view that emotions don't
exist or don't matter or that they're
like irrational emotions are more
rational than people give them credit
for and at the very basis and apologies
to Ben Shapiro
facts do in feelings in many ways do
inform facts uh there is some reason I
don't know I can't articulate what it is
why I like this song over that song even
if the other song is melodically
compositionally yeah feelings don't care
about your facts in that regard right
right but it's not I'm not liking this
song because some capitalists told me to
or because of my or maybe I am but I I
don't think that's entirely it can be
described entirely that because then
we'd all like the same songs that's not
the case it would be the mathematically
best melodically harmoniously best song
yeah I mean I see this I've been playing
around a lot with this in my own sort of
personal life trying to
after this period of you know 600
episodes and whatever five years or
something that I've done on the podcast
uh and and praying at the altar of
cerebral horsepower and cognition and
all these smart people that I've got to
spend time with
then trying to reintegrate I don't know
like some embodied emotional sense of
just knowing and wisdom without sounding
too Austin psychedelicy right not some
woo out there Rhonda burn the secret
[ __ ] just
your programming and your nature and
your intuition is able to aggregate more
information than your prefrontal cortex
is able to rationalize yes the reason
that you crossed the street because that
person was on that side why break it
down for me tell me what it was about
that person specifically that you had an
issue with
well I I don't know it just it was
something I got a feeling well yeah
because you're able to out the way that
they walked the way that they looked the
body making all of that stuff right uh
and like I say from a personal
standpoint now trying to
reintegrate those two things so when you
scale it up to the size of an entire
uh Nation I I can see why there would be
you know this conflict within me with
this I can see why there would be
conflict when it comes to trying to
build a National philosophy of this and
also this idea that everything is
quantifiable like if you asked me to
rank all the songs I like I don't know
that and that's a you know very
obviously easy example I know that other
people do it and I think it would be
extremely Dynamic you know there's some
days when you want to listen to that
ballot and there's some days when you
want to listen to some synths so this
idea that you could kind of sit down and
just figure it out for even one person
is kind of anything if it's yourself
it's kind of absurd so where did this
passion for revolution in the Soviet
Union come from because it's so Marx it
came from Marx it's so fervent yeah so
Marx was a
he took the Christian eschatology this
kind of the Book of Revelation of Saint
John this idea that we're going to have
this you know big Revolution and it's
going to bring about you know the
Heavenly kingdom here on Earth he didn't
use those terms but he very much fed and
this isn't really disputed he very much
fed into this kind of vision of bringing
uh a new world peace
um through their state and you know
Mark's very famously and English talked
about you know after it all works out
the state's going to wither away because
Humanity would be all equal and we won't
need the government anymore and
everything's just going to kind of work
itself out but they really thought that
and they're not entirely wrong that we
are going to create now that we the
industrial revolution has happened and
we have technology and we have
electricity we have the capacity to
remake reality into something that the
world had never seen before and
something that's going to make things
great for everybody so they were right
in the sense that they now had the
capacity to remake society and it's
something the world never seen before
but there there's other examples of this
which is plastic surgery was invented as
a result of World War one because for
the first time you had these soldiers
coming back from you know the front and
they were all deformed and mangled in
ways that you know hadn't been seen
before and if you look at Googling you
know first photos the first people who
have plastic surgery it's it's
completely nightmarish you know but you
have to take those halting steps to get
to the point where it's you know
contemporary Beverly Hills but this you
know this era this was you keep in mind
in World War one you had the king and
then you had a Kaiser and then you had
the head of the Ottoman Empire and you
had you know Archduke friends Ferdinand
and you had the Czar and then you had
the I think Italy had a king so even
though it's like 1914 to 1917 and 19
through 1920 in some senses for us this
is just like another world like I mean
obviously Queen Elizabeth just recently
passed away but she was a symbol you
know she's not running things but this
was a time where these people really
were running things and this really was
a break from that kind of tradition of
aristocracy or landed gentry into like
all right this is going to be the
ultimate sense of democrac
what was happening in the Soviet Union
before it became the Soviet Union why
was it primed in such a way well I don't
think that well that's the thing it
wasn't so if you read Marxist you know
Orthodoxy what would prime a country for
this kind of workers Revolution would be
industrialization right and severe uh
monopolization and concentration of
wealth so Marx would expect it to happen
in like the U.S or Britain or German
yeah that was it not Hargreaves what was
the name of that factory where everybody
kicked off and then they just brought
new workers in oh yeah in the steel
mills in um um I'm liking the term right
now near Pittsburgh yes um but no but
they it would be Nationwide like you
would Nationwide have the workers be
completely oppressed and the workers are
going to rise up and it's going to be
worldwide thing but you don't go from
like this feudal the czaris it was
basically feudalism you know in many
ways up until uh the Czar fell and your
people were like working the soil it was
very primitive conditions
the Czar Falls you have the first
Revolution they have their Parliament
but people had been under this thumb of
czars for hundreds of years they're not
used to representative democracy the the
parliament had very little power uh to
do really anything and then when Lenin
came in and basically seized power in
1917 late 1917. it was like no one
really know what that meant it's like
okay the bolstery is running things now
and they very quickly realized uh uh
what it meant that he wasn't messing
around this is a different breed yeah
yeah this is this isn't like the
difference between like the Democratic
party and the Green Party
foreign
thing that I didn't know was that
the original Inception of this was in
the hopes of becoming the first the tip
of the Spear of a worldwide movement
that the Soviet Union would be the test
case they almost saw themselves as the
opportunity to prove that this could
happen and then from there they did see
themselves that yes and then they but
what you've got what you mentioned
earlier on that we'll get on to with
regards to the press and the way that
this was
um interpreted and responded to in the
US specifically you had some people in
the US that were seeing it as that
experiment too so you had a kind of
collusion like a philosophical collusion
that was going on uh across the Atlantic
well it wasn't just the collusion so
this was the big argument between you
know a lot of times in politics to this
day uh you'll have there and in religion
you have the putative argument where
it's like all right uh you had the
argument between agnostics and Orthodox
Christianity is Christ co-equal with God
the father or is Christ aborted to him
that's you know one of the air that's
the Aryan heresy I believe and if you
but a lot of times just about power you
just have an excuse to you know fight
one another so Trotsky uh who was again
letting his right hand man he had the
vision which is more in line with
Orthodox Marxism that instead of
thinking of Nations you think of classes
right so the workers workers of the
World Unite you have nothing loose but
you're chains that the great Marxist
quote right so his idea is the worker
working class in Russia and Russia have
more in common with the working class
with the working class in America than
they do with the bourgeoisie in Russia
right and that this that makes a lot of
sense and this is one of the reasons
they were very much against the the
Great War they're like why are the
workers and the poor losing their lives
for the sake of czars and Sultans and
Kaisers like we're the ones who pay the
price for the wealthy this is absolutely
obscene this is our opportunity to you
know what they would call imperialist
Wars or capitalist Wars put a stop to it
and have the workers of the world
basically unify and create this maybe
not literally a paradise but certainly
the next generation of humanity you know
when Stalin came in and he saw that
wasn't happening he was like all right
you could have socialism in one country
but that was kind of the idea that all
right it's going to start here
and then it's good and this was a very
real concern because Marxism predicted
that capitalism would be destroyed by
its own contradictions right and then
1929 happens you know this is 12 years
after Lenin seizes power in in what
became the Soviet Union you have the
Great Depression things are
unprecedentedly bad for unprecedented
long time there have been depressions
before but they never went out for that
long or that badly people are looking
around and all the marxists are saying
with a straight face we predicted this
and now you're seeing our predictions
and people a lot of people were like all
right there's this these are the Death
Rows of capitalism and in that sense FDR
you know who is you know reviled by many
conservatives can be seen as the
right-wing response because the
alternative to FDR wasn't Calvin
Coolidge the alternative to FDR was very
easily could have been a workers
Revolution and having a Communist
dictatorship here in the States what was
that quote about uh the capitalists will
sell us the rope and we'll Tie The Noose
yeah Lenin is alleged to have said and
apparently he never did that the
capitalists will sell us the rope with
which we'll hang them yes I was in
yeah that's funny and then do you think
that he was actually true when he said
that once we've reached the Utopia that
we're supposed to this communist Utopia
that we will be able to
discard these methods no because the
reason communism doesn't work isn't
simply due to the human nature being bad
which doesn't even make sense because if
you're basing your philosophy on human
nature it is the basis for your
philosophy you can't say it's good or
bad it's like saying well I'm gonna
build a airplane and it's going to let
people fly from their own power but the
people are bad well if you're building
around people can't fly the problem is
in your program not in the person or
you're you know building around the
problem is calculation so without a
market to set price you do not know how
much to produce so you know a very
obvious example is you don't have to
know anything about comic books at all
but if you go to a comic book store and
you see Detective Comics number 26 is
500 and Detective Comics 27 is 50 000
and Detective Comics 28 is six you know
six thousand something about 20 that's
number 27 is special you don't have to
know it's the first experience of Batman
but you do know have to know is that
either apply this issue is very low or
the demand is very high but even not
knowing the facts as to why that price
is information about this is something
that the market is asking for more of
but if I am setting a price if I am as
the government saying Detective Comics
Number 27 is going to be sold at one
thousand dollars very quickly it's going
to be a complete sold out everywhere
you're not going to be able to find it
because it's way below the market if
you're going to be able to sell it's
maybe going to be at the black market
and that's going to be blank blank store
shelves on the other hand if I say we're
going to produce x amount of copies of
detector Comics 27 then you're going to
have these massive surpluses because at
a certain point if you don't have the
price you don't know how much to produce
so having without having a price
mechanism you can have Central planning
work because it's not going to have
information about how much you need
because at the same time even if I tell
you the commissar listen my factory
needs 100 more Nails I still that those
nails are still competing with screws
and bolts but also bread and milk and
cars and CDs and computers every product
is in competition every other product
and a currency is what kind of
adjudicates those disputes between the
demands but if you're just telling me I
need 50 nails and he's telling me I need
50 pacemakers both are a need how do I
figure out which is needed more and
that's what price indicates is that the
fundamental structural issue when it
comes to Communism well when it comes to
Central planning yes
in my opinion what what else what are
the other elements well I think the
other elements it's very very expensive
to try to in every sense the word to try
to force a population to live according
to your ideology at a certain point you
need a lot of them to buy in or to have
it enforce themselves because you can
only pay so many police to beat so many
people and at a certain point people are
like I don't want to be beating people
anymore
is there an argument to be made that in
that case a capitalist system that
applies status and gives Prestige to
people who are the most productive uh
they are allowed to accrue that through
the agreement of other people saying
that yes your job title and high-rise
office is something that quite rightly
should you should feel proud about is
there an argument to be made that
capitalism is just a more nefarious way
of motivating workers to do the exact
same thing well I don't think that CEOs
are held in the same Regard in any
capitalist country as like Stalin was
you know you know Steve Jobs Elon Musk
is like there was I think he's maybe
he's number two now richest person on
earth the way people [ __ ] on Elon Musk
25 8 on on Twitter alone even before he
bought Twitter there was no shortage of
people condemning Elon Musk or
condemning Steve Jobs or condemning uh
Bill Gates George Soros I I don't think
successful CEOs
um other than
uh what's his name who run Apple for
many years with the turtleneck before he
died
yeah Steve Jobs Steve Jobs maybe he's on
a pedestal I'm thinking of Jeff Bezos
sorry I got this confused I think very
few CEOs are regarded with any sort of
reverence uh in the same way that the
kind of leaders in these countries are
expected to be revered you're not
hanging up a photo even if you're a big
uh [ __ ] poster of Elon Musk in your
house
would it be right for me to characterize
the two prongs the two sort of most
brutal prongs of existence in the Soviet
Union one as being the food and lack of
access so famine on one side and then on
the other side being the combination of
State Police and sort of State enforced
uh surveillance from the population on
itself that those would be that seems
like that gets an awful lot of focus
not a food and too much brutality coming
from the state and also uh engine like
caused by its own population on itself
but I I think
I think in the west we can look at
things as discrete issues right we can
say it's a problem that none of people
have access to health care even in
places where they have the NHS right we
can say that
um education is an issue they're
teaching kids things that they shouldn't
and they're not teaching kids that they
should or we can talk about you know
pornography with young men too many
people are consuming pornography it's
still tears to health but these are
looked at in a way as kind of discrete
issues I think the issue with
totalitarianism is you don't get to
separate out these things like
everything feeds into another and it's
not and it's kind of like if you remove
the secret police you still have you
know you're at school all the time
you're learning all this stuff you see
you're you're still consuming the media
with the with all the issues
um the fact that your job is basically
assigned to you you know at a certain
point being late to work became a felony
even though it was not at all reliable
the the public transport system in these
countries so
I don't I don't I may I think
we we could both sit here until we're
blue in the face but until we've lived
in these places we are not going to know
what the worst part of it is it's kind
of like we're it's kind of like Plato's
Cave just how about the famine gut
which which one well I mean pick
whichever of your favorites there was
but I didn't have any favorites right
most certainly but if you're talking
about the holiday more in the 19 early
1930s you know Stalin's war in Ukraine
um red famine is a book by Anne
Applebaum which I recommend enormously
even though she's uh got some pretty bad
TDS uh which doesn't at all uh um take
away from the enormous service she's
done in her research
um they just decided all right we're
going to liquidate the cool locks and
the cool locks were these kind of
wealthy Farmers uh and very and we're
gonna kill them or Deport them to God
knows aware with their families but very
quickly a kulak became anyone who owns
like a cow
and a kulak became someone in your
village you don't like you just got to
turn them in accuse them of being a
kulak and then you're rewarded with
grain for your family so the incentives
were very heavily
to turn on your neighbors
um and you weren't allowed to leave your
Village
um and they took as much grain as they
could
and they sold it for export
um and people I mean the levels of
starvation were in the millions and this
was by Design so they came back in the
middle of the night you know these these
activists to search houses and if you
they could look this is the sick thing
that I learned about the holiday more is
your own body would betray you they
could take one look at you and see
you're not starving that means
you're less gone that means you're
hiding food whereas the food and if you
don't give me the food that means I know
you're hiding it so that means I'm
entitled to burn down your house and put
you out in the winter in the Ukrainian
winter and good luck with that because
if you don't if you're not handing it to
me you must be hiding it and therefore
you're a coolock and what else ended up
happening
is in the rest of uh the USSR they were
told you don't have food because the
cool locks are hoarding all the grain
they were created this kind of uh
National out group
and then there was this kind of level of
hatred which was later kind of
paralleled with Hitler against the Jews
to the sense of these people you're
suffering because these people are are
you know they're getting wealthy at your
expense and there's this one very
disturbing story of this young woman who
made her way to the city she got out of
her Village starving on a line begging
for food she had like across the Brenner
hand and the store Keepers like this is
what you you filthy corlex this is what
you deserve and God help anyone who
helped her and that she like died on the
spot and everyone was basically happy
about it because it's like we're on this
line there's no bread in the store
because of her and people like her
I don't think that it was the same
famine but there's a story about
babies that were so hungry that they
cried for so long that they couldn't
even cry anymore and there was a story
about a mother whose baby was crying and
then the mother just started beating the
baby
yeah Dave Smith brought up that that was
the story that got to him the most
that's pretty yeah like you know people
started swarming these train stations to
try to get out of wherever they were and
there was just this one scene where this
mom and she's lost and and when the
human body is starving for that long the
mind starts degenerating and you know
it's functional insanity and she's there
and the kids crying because there's no
milk coming out and she snaps and she
starts beating the crap out of her
kitten from everybody and then she kind
of reverts to normal and
you know that was one of those scenes
where it didn't get to me that much
because it's so removed
from any no reference box I have no
reference point for this like I can I
can't it's hard for me to for any of us
to imagine what it's like being that
hungry for that long right even that is
like I mean I know people who've been on
the show Survivor but they know that if
any minute they can get to food and and
they're only there for 30 days max and
you know they're in a tropical Paradise
you know so on and so forth and even so
that's bad but you know they like you
get used to it but that's the closest
you know any of us are gonna get uh uh
to understanding what that's like and
and the the thing that is really
um that I I would think the darkest
aspect is not just the hunger it's the
knowledge that this isn't changing like
this there's no hang on you know we're
in war once this war is over you know
it's like no no this is peace time and
you're not allowed to leave your village
and if God help you if you find food
it's going to be taken from you I I I I
I can't wrap my head if you don't
produce enough food then we're going to
ask you to produce five times the amount
of food that you didn't produce and
accuse you of stealing it yeah
was this organized was the famine so the
famine was created by the state yes by
Stalin why because he wanted to break
Ukraine he wanted to break he wanted to
collectivize the countryside and and for
a long time the Ukraine is very famously
known as the breadbasket of Europe
because they had these fertile lands and
so on and so forth and they were
producing all the crops and he's like
our and the ukrainians obviously
historically into this day spoiler alert
have enormous amount of rivalry if not
contempt for the Russian people and vice
versa and he's like all right like you
know Ukraine became part of the USSR and
he's like we have to break Ukraine and
and you know did you break the spirits
of the people and not have any semblance
of resistance to our scheme and in this
he succeeded uh maybe not entirely but
very heavily
who is Walter Durante
oh um Walter Durante was um you did his
voice for the promo commercial because
he was British he was the New York Times
man in Moscow he he won a Pulitzer uh he
got to interview Stalin which was an
enormous accomplishment for a Westerner
um and while this starvation was this
war in Ukraine uh and it wasn't just
Ukraine of course people were starving
all over the Soviet Universe where it
was localized I want to be clear
um he was writing the New York Times how
you know people who were saying there's
hunger it's just anti-soviet propaganda
uh this is just and the quote is there
is no famine nor is there likely to be
the Russian people are merely tightening
their belts now that's a very
unfortunate choice of words I'm not
trying to even be humorous you only have
to tighten your belt when you don't have
enough food it's not a fashion Choice it
means your pants are falling off because
you're losing weight and you lose weight
uh in two ways died in exercise which
they weren't doing or lack of caloric
intake
um and while this whole thing was
happening you know he's repeatedly uh
talking about how it's the people who
are complaining or just the loud mouths
everyone else is busy doing the work and
putting time in the fields and and
producing so and so forth the Russians
have tightened their belts before
um and when Gareth Jones
who is another who's a British
journalist figured out what was
happening because he got off his train a
stop early and just walked through the
countryside and saw for himself what was
happening the entire Western press Corps
either there's differing accounts
whether this was they sat down and said
dude consciously or they just did it
because they knew what their marching
orders were called him a liar and a
propagandist and so on and so forth and
Durante was the one who took charge of
this whole campaign to smear him as a
complete fraud there was a second one
another British man Malcolm ruggeridge
whose parents were members of the Fabian
Society was a hardcore Lefty uh he got
information as well and then as a result
of this when he kind of leaked the news
of this kind of man-made uh atrocity he
was basically couldn't get work after
that because whether it was because he
had the wrong politics or whether
because he exposed his colleagues as
worse than fools as in League with the
devil
um you know he paid the price but that's
the question Walter Durante wasn't
giving an accurate account of what was
happening inside the Soviet Union as he
later admitted yeah
why what was what was his motivation for
do for I I think it's very hard to get
into the heads of someone who is
putting his name front and center in
terms of denying genocide I mean I have
all the quotes that are in the book
where he explicitly said there's no need
for anyone to go to these Villages for a
reporter to tell people you don't need
to go check it out for yourself in a
country which he would clearly admit is
quite secretive is to me unconscionable
I I mean whatever the motivation was it
can't be good uh the best I can think of
that would make the most sense to me is
status right he was the dean of the
Moscow press Corps he was you know the
big shot uh and basically if it's
revealed that he doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about as it was and as
he admitted it's like well then what
good are you so Upton Sinclair has this
quote that's ascribed to him I think he
actually did say this one where he said
it's almost impossible to convince a man
of something when his salary is
dependent on him not being convinced of
it so it might be as simple as that
um yeah I don't know he seemed like a
very
um
I I couldn't work out his motivations I
couldn't work out whether it was
complicity whether he had political
sympathy for what was going on over
there whether it was simply the
associated reflected glory and status
that he was getting from having this
sort of access to people that no Western
journalist would or should do and
perhaps a blend of all of them I suppose
one of the other things that happened
obviously Downstream from or maybe there
was also a theory that he was being
blackmailed to some extent so that could
that would make some sense that the
Russians had some Intel on him and they
didn't want it revealed who knows that's
interesting
one of the other things that happened
Downstream from there being widespread
famine and so actually going back to the
famine for a second
if the use of the famine from Stalin was
to beat and erode the Ukrainian spirit
surely they could have considered we
might just kill them all
it might end up as having no people left
in the Ukraine to conquer
well I I mean they killed they sure
killed a lot of them but I think it was
I don't that's a good question
I wonder if that was a concern
I guess because they were given some
grain it's not like they were given
literally none right they took it all
but they gave some back yes
so what happens Downstream from a famine
next thing that happens is you have uh
an ever increasing paranoia within the
people who are in charge of what's going
on
uh among the populace and this I mean
there's a story where is it Stalin who's
who gives the
the police
and a quota for each different area
he I need 10 000 criminals from this
region in this region in this region in
this region which kind of like the kids
from earlier on drive around and tell us
who your accomplices are caused the law
enforcement to go around they were
retrofitting the number of criminals to
their quota for criminals as opposed to
catching people that were doing crime
yeah this is something that I think
again westerners have a hard time
wrapping their heads around and even I
have a hard time wrapping my head around
um Stalin would sit down
and you have a piece of paper and he'd
be like all right in Kazakhstan you need
to arrest 50 000 people or whatever the
number is in you know in Saint
Petersburg or Leningrad you need to rest
10 000 in leviv you need to rest this
many and it was the job of the uh nkvd
or the KGB whatever it was at the time
to be like all right this is how many
people we have to find and his last of
the uh secret police heads barrier is
most known for his quote uh show me the
man I'll show you the crime and they
prided themselves on getting confessions
out of people who were perfectly
innocent and the argument is well if we
arrested you you must have done
something and if you're saying that
we're arresting innocent people that in
and of itself is being
counter-revolutionary and criticizing
the government so that in itself is a
crime so yeah and I my understanding is
these lists are still in like the
archives in the Kremlin like they still
have them this isn't just like hearsay
like they have the piece of paper where
he's got the names of the different
places and the numbers what were some of
the tools that they used to extract
confessions from people
um that was a very hard
um
section to write about because I think
people here
we think about like what the police will
do to get a confession out of you it's
like okay they're gonna yell at you
they're going to rough you up you know
things like that it's like all right I I
that's what we're used to as like police
brutality
so at a certain point they lower the
death penalty
for children
um
so I think it was 12 or 14 12 12.
and this became this was a big problem
for Defenders of the Soviet Union
because this wasn't like hearsay this
was public and they're like
what are you what are you doing and one
of the reasons what they were doing is
if they would arrest people
they would have a death warrant for that
person's kid signed on the desk of the
interrogator
so you know your dad who I got to meet a
few weeks ago in Austin he's come in he
knows he didn't do anything look I'll
just talk to them it'll be fine
and there's the death warrant for Chris
in his view signed like it's it's ready
to be delivered he'll confess to
anything I mean they they were having
Jews confessing and working for Hitler
um and there was another time when you
know they brought in someone who was an
old Bolshevik and the old Bolsheviks
were the people who fought the Czar they
were like the terrorists of their time
like people who were fought with Lenin
and they were hardened men you know the
[ __ ] would arrest them the katarga
system which uh presaged the um the
gulags they'd send with Siberia you know
middle of nowhere and these men did that
time for their political views and they
brought in one of them
and they called his I think it was his
mom uh or his mother-in-law and check
because she's watching his kids right
there and it's like oh are your kids
okay and they're like yeah and so they
just turned him he's like okay I'll sell
whatever you want you know so the when
you
again this something that is hard for us
to understand the West you know we are
all used to these movies where like you
know someone's brought in Tom Cruise is
tied to a chair and they're beating the
crap out of him he's like you know
spitting blood at them is just glaring
at them
you bring in it's like we have your kids
the calculus is and you know they're not
bluffing it's not like we have them but
like you know we don't really want to do
anything like they don't care and you
know they don't care
um and when that happens uh I don't
think any of us can understand what our
thought processes would be like what was
the conveyor
oh so the conveyor yeah there were so
many different techniques that they used
the conveyor it was called a conveyor
because you know they'd wake you up in
the middle of the night and someone
would be yelling at you for four hours
to confess and they'd make you write
down your whole life story and they rip
it up and write it again and then every
element oh so when this happened and
then when the guy who's interviewing
gets tired they just bring somebody else
like conveyor belt and you're up for
days at a time and as soon as there's
any discrepancy and was the movie you
and I went to see was it Amelie or was
it the southern movie oh why were you
lying about what movie you saw with
Chris and then it's like okay so now
they have now they have 10 this is ten
times you lied to us look at you're not
a trust it's very easy when someone
hasn't slept when every little slight
details being examined and the guy is
just a fresh one through the door and
the thing is the interrogators often
knew this guy hasn't done anything it
was just like he's got a job to do to
get you to sign that piece of paper uh
and the quicker we could do this the
quicker we get on with our Our Lives
there's a study that was done on TSA
agents in in airports and what they
wanted to see was if given a outcome
will people retrofit reality in order to
be able to achieve it so the original
study was actually faces that were
either angry or happy and there was a
hundred images and you had to pick
between them angry happy happy angry
angry but after the first 50 images it
was only angry images
but people still kept on picking
happiness out of anger even though it's
quite obviously angry images because
they had a predetermined idea that this
is something that I should be searching
for and it was used to extrapolate that
to a question around TSA agents which is
that everybody has gone through the
scenario of there being nothing in their
bag and the security Guy saying we're
gonna have to open this up because some
things come up and you open it up and
he's like well there's nothing in here I
don't know what could have come up and
you don't know if it appeared on the
screen in a strange way or whatever but
there would be a question to be asked if
every single person arrived at the
airport with their bags perfectly packed
and no Contraband or any of the other
stuff in it
the TSA agents are still likely to pick
out issues within that because that is
what they're optimizing for that's the
function that they're optimizing for and
it's kind of the same with regards to
this oh yeah and then it's even worse
because if you think about it this way
what if that TSA agent is told
ten percent like one percent of the
populace or the people coming through
are potential terrorists like we know
through our research in our studies it's
one percent or point five percent
whatever small number and then you're as
the TSA agent is putting everyone
through
well if you put everyone through you're
either grossly incompetent or
maybe you're a potential terrorist
because they would love to work for the
TSA and now how you disprove that you're
a potential terrorist when the proof is
you're letting through Point you're
relating through literally every
potential terrorist right you haven't
clagged one single person so this must
be by Design one or two we can allow
that's you know negligent whatever every
single potential terrorist you let
through what's going on here Mr TSA
agent and that was part of the knife
that the the that was pointed to that
was hanging over their heads yeah there
was this sort of Damocles over pretty
much everybody what was the scalping
thing
yeah so they were very creative with
their tortures one of them was they
would tie a rope around someone's like
head I don't think this was done very
commonly and then they would have like a
stick attached to it and they would turn
it until just basically the skin off top
their head popped off
to me honestly the psychological
tortures were much more horrific because
we can all wrap our heads thanks to
Hollywood about like people just being
beaten in fingernails put off and
someone dislocates your shoulder we've
seen those movies you know with the
actors just getting the crap kicked out
of them and jaw broken and whatever
this you don't dare show
even in like a Silence of the Lamb's
context a movie where someone is brought
in
and their kid if that kid is being shown
hostage in a movie he's gonna get saved
right they're not going to show that you
sign the confession and they shoot the
kid anyway what was that General
Secretary stanislav kozia well that was
the hardest the hardest scene that was
the worst scene in the book
um I think Peter fector might be the
worst but this was the one where
um because he's also a very evil person
right stanislav kosior and he was head
of Ukraine
um they Stalin brought him to Moscow and
made him like uh like second in command
or gave him a major position like in
January I think of 38 and by May he's
arrested
and we don't know exactly what the
tortures were done to him but he was a
good Bolshevik strong you know Stalin
means Man of Steel they Pride themselves
in their ruthlessness and this is
something the interrogators had to do
it's like you're not going to feel
sentimental because this enemy of the
people is being tortured what kind of
person are you right like you're a
strong Soviet and you know they could
have kept him up all night they could
have thrown cold water who knows what
they pulled there was one um Russian
military Guy where they pulled out all
his teeth and then when he was pardoned
they gave him steel teeth and he was
instrumental in fighting the Nazis
during World War II and Stalin was like
oops sorry buddy
um
and the the thing with that scene is you
know they did something to him which was
not done to many other people uh as far
as my Research indicates and the
question is when the torturers reach
this kind of apex of torture is it
something that they always had in the
back of their minds we don't want to go
there but we know we can do it or is it
that this guy is a major name we have to
break him and we have to go into
Uncharted Territory were they letting
him think he's gonna outwit them or were
they like was he actually doing it was
he like going for you know like what's
his name um uh in gitmo uh Khalid what
he was the water board like 20 times or
some crazy number which no one had ever
done before they're like what this guy
is just like a beast right so at a
certain point they brought in his
teenage daughter and raped her in front
of him and then he broke and when you
read
you know even though the guy's a monster
he was complicit in the genocide of the
ukrainians and you know
just many torches on his name just to
kind of
try to get into his head to be like I
don't care what these people are going
to do to me I'm innocent let me talk to
Stalin you know you know I know how this
works I I'm a proud Bolshevik I've never
would never betray the people like
spitting his blood in their faces and
then she comes in it's like what's she
doing here and he's like oh you're
innocent huh okay
and then he just saw and the thing is
she killed herself he got he outlived
her she threw herself in front of a
train
um
and that's the kind of thing where when
people think of Oppression in the west
we think solitary confinement
cops not letting you sleep they're
beating the crap out of you they're
breaking your limbs
I think all of that is something that
would be excruciating no question for us
but when you're watching someone assault
your kids and no they're not going to
have any consequences for it and like
that's a wrap for you and it's just like
we don't know none of us in the West
I think
under except under maybe ridiculous
circumstances
can appreciate that sense of
powerlessness
like even if someone is solitary
confinement uh shout out to Ross
Albrecht can still write letters to
people
receive information you know read a book
or something there's a little bit of uh
sovereignty sovereignty
and that which is just so
obscene in like almost a spiritual sense
is and the thing is our heads would
never go there like we we don't think in
terms like this and they were just very
the Soviets were very very
um
conniving and crafty in their
machinations
why was this extreme paranoia
overbearing police and Secret Service
involvement heavy use of cold Sellers
and hot sellers learning about that as
well was pretty [ __ ] awful 16 men
locked in a room where it was so small
that you couldn't even touch the ground
and the only thing worse than that was
the cold cellar which was basically
where you were left to freeze and this
super cold Siberian yeah they put you in
a no they put you in a pit like
basically like a like a basement and
they threw ice water on you naked
not good yeah why why do you do the cold
pledges that's true that's true maybe I
would have loved it they're a cool yeah
maybe I'd have loved it now it's cool
yeah just without the psychedelics and
the ketamine um
why is all of this happening why is it
why are there quotas for how many
criminals need to be found
is this
an an inevitable byproduct of
um trying to search for revolution is
this because of internal corruption is
this cultural within the political Elite
like what what's driving this type of
there's several several things and and
to be clear not every decade the Soviet
Union was as bad as this this was the
great Stalin's great Terror in the in
the late 30s
um
part of it is
if you look at
an axis between collectivism and
individualism right a big part of
collectivism is
to make sure that no individual has too
much power and we can understand that
thing like a lot of people would be
uncomfortable with like Trump or Soros
or Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos being like
all right this guy's accountable to no
one you know he's Untouchable you know
this I can understand that that kind of
argument but when you extrapolate that
Nationwide and you make it so that no
individual has any power everyone is
only a function of society
what that means in practice is
again things like this where you were
just completely powerless and helpless
and that's by Design that's number one
number two is Stalin's goal
was
um
to have it as public
greater good for society as possible so
anything private
was a threat to his vision but what that
means is
if me and you are friends or your
parents these are private bonds as
opposed to public bonds for everyone and
right away that is the first step toward
a conspiracy because if your loyalty is
to your dad as opposed to society well I
can't have that because everyone has to
be working for everybody else and
especially someone like him Stalin who
was personally very paranoid any kind of
organization
whether it's a classroom uh Factory
neighborhood if they're working together
that's a private society as opposed to
the public Society so he did everything
in his power to atomize
Soviet society as much as possible and
to have people look at each other to
have this be a as low trust the society
as possible that you don't know who is
going to turn you in for what and to
have enormous incentives for people to
turn in their neighbor's colleagues
family members uh co-workers and so on
and so forth to maintain their status
just maintain their homes there were
jokes you know Russians had these things
where you could use humor to say things
that were otherwise unspeakable where
you know people had to live in
apartments together with other families
right and all it would take is a phone
call to the secret police and be like
he's a coolock or you know he's hoarding
uh gold and the joke was like oh my gosh
we turned in Masha but Dasha has a
better room you know it's it's it but
all it would take is a phone call they
vanish and now you've got their space
and so the incentives are there
especially if not everyone's a good
roommate
it seems like a lot of the
a lot of this story was either
perpetuated created or driven by Stalin
yes
what is he as a man is he
evil is he captured by an ideology he
was nowhere near as much of an ideologue
as Lenin so uh that is real and he was a
he was a thug he came up as a bank
robber a a hooligan he was not some kind
of like Trotsky is very much the
intellectual
um vision of the Communist and he
despite you know people making excuses
for Trotsky as we saw with I talk about
the construct Rebellion he had no
problem putting people up against the
wall who got in his way so the reason he
didn't kill as many people Stalin is
because he got deposed and deported so
when he's in the depths of Mexico
plowing Frida Kahlo he's not in a
position to really be ordering you know
rapes and executions so I that it was
very heavily
influenced by Stalin but again
everything that he did There's in the
west you know when all this stuff became
kind of verified especially by
khrushchev's secret speech in 56 where
he's like yeah all this stuff that style
is true and when you hear coming from
the guy who succeeded Stalin as opposed
to like Western capitalist propaganda
you're like oh crap we gotta look at
this Square in the face instead of
sweeping on the rug it's kind of like
all the things that Stalin did Lenin had
implemented and you know Emma Goldman
Alexander Berkman made that clear at the
time before you know Stalin was even in
power
also something that happened right no
they did it after Stalin was in power
sorry 89 was when the Berlin Wall fell
right so it's a year after I was born uh
so for me I I didn't know
what it meant I didn't know where it ran
I didn't know why it happened I didn't
realize that there was actually four
quadrants to Germany yeah it had been
split up between was it the French
Russians
British who's the other one Americans or
the Americans right whatever I don't
know you got a bit of Germany I can't
remember it I've read a very big book in
not very much time okay like give me
give me a break
um
you talk about the absurdity of
splitting us not only a country but a
city yeah in half
did you look at what the process of that
occurring was like the creation of a
wall the building of a wall where me
that lives on this street and you that
lives two streets in that direction are
now completely apart yeah you know that
was one of the things that was
interesting when I was writing that
chapter
you know and how I framed it is it would
have been considered Unthinkable because
no one had ever thought to thought of it
before how do you disintegrate a city
the whole point of a city or one of the
big points is I can get easily from
point A to point B everyone's physically
close here's the government sector
here's the business sector here's the
cultural center and they're all you know
in proximity to one another you don't
need a car in most cities or certain
cities and everything's just integrated
so it's like what if you wanted to kind
of if Manhattan you know take Times
Square but now Times Square is a
separate country it's it's like okay
like if we would have to sit down and
really do the math here it's like okay
you can get there through the subway
you've got the streets you've got these
tall buildings like some of the
buildings are interconnected with these
skywalks like how would you separate
this out and they basically did this in
East Germany they're like all right all
these people because West Germany West
Berlin excuse me is wholly contained
within East Germany I had a lot of I had
thought as a kid and I think a lot of
Americans still think that Berlin is
right in the center of Germany and when
Germany is split into East Germany West
Germany it just got split in half and
you got you had a wall right down the
middle it wasn't the entire city of
Berlin is in
um East Germany and closer to Poland
than it is to West Germany so they're
like all right if you go from east to
west West Berlin once you step foot in
West Berlin you're in West Germany and
you're basically free and all the people
kept Crossing that border and they're
like we're losing people by the
thousands and not just people we're
losing our like the brain drain we're
losing the engineers we're losing the
doctors we're losing the people who you
know kind of are punching above their
weight in terms of production and
they're like all right we're gonna
separate out the city into two halves
and you have to worry about the sewers
people are going to sneak it through the
sewers you have to worry about the
streets you have to worry about you know
water pipes like every aspect that
integrates a city they had to figure out
how are we going to disintegrate this
Subway Lines uh and they did it and the
thing is
when they did it like overnight the
first elements even in America you know
President Kennedy didn't really know
what to make of it because they never
entered their head that someone would
try to do something like this because
it's not like Berlin is small so to
Encompass a city within a wall like
imagine someone even encompassing like
Austin in a wall it's like what like
this wall would be just gigantic and it
would take forever and they did it and
people started losing their lives trying
to cross you know very very quickly and
the stories that I love that chapter a
lot
because there's a lot of
um just very dark moments where people
just want to cross the street so they
could celebrate their birthday with
their sister and they get shot but
there's also moments where people like
I'm gonna do something about this you
know and escaping
um and just using their Ingenuity to
kind of give it you know my favorite
story is the one with the sports car I
love that story
Hans next door I think is the name yeah
so before that what was the citizens
Escape tunnel
will you move the college kids it was
elderly people
senior citizens Escape yeah so the
senior citizens tunnel Andrew Heaton
told me this story I I I'm very grateful
to him basically there was a chicken
coop in East I always cry when I always
lose it when I tell this story
um and I I you tell it so many times you
think you're going to be able to tell it
calmly and you never can or at least I
can't because there were a bunch of
senior citizens old people and they dug
this tunnel from East Berlin to West
Berlin and they dug it six feet tall and
which is going to take a lot longer than
something a crawl space and they asked
this old guy why you guys built this
tunnel so tall and he said my wife's
done crawling
so it's just this beautiful thing that
they all got out
isn't that great
[ __ ] amazing
what about the sports car what about God
isn't that a great story unbelievable so
I think his name's Hansen Meister please
uh double check it on this uh he fell in
love he was one of the people who was
commuting between East and West Berlin
uh because you still had thanks to the
post-world War II laws you were allowed
to cross the border if you're a certain
type of Citizen
um and he fell in love with an East
German girl
and he's like all right I gotta get her
ass to West Germany so he goes to
Checkpoint Charlie and you know that's
the big one that was the most famous uh
um for the exchanges and [ __ ] happened
doesn't it yeah it's like it was the big
border crossing and he looks at that bar
you know even nowadays you have a
parking garage you pay the ticket and
the bar goes up and allows the car to go
through and as the guys you know he's
making his Crossing he very carefully
measures it and he's like all right this
is how tall it is so he's like I know
what to do I gotta find a car that would
fit Under This Bar and I could just
drive under it so he finds I think was
an Astrid Martin it was a British car I
remember he rents it
he puts the girlfriend in the back seat
and he's like well if I'm gonna flee
with her I gotta bring Mom along he
brings the mother-in-law and then he
packs a ton of bricks he puts her in the
trunk with bricks in case they start
shooting her right and at so there were
two points where you have to check he
gets passed through the first Guard the
guard waves into the second point and
instead of going the second point
because he had taken off the windshield
also he just and he took out some air
from the tires he floors it right drives
under the bar and makes his way to
freedom and as I put in the book you
would think that the guards would just
stand there shaking their fists they
weren't because they didn't know what
the hell that just happened
um and they got married and it's just
this beautiful
uh that's the other thing about the
white pill there are so many moments
where even in this kind of nightmare
countries there are these few just
random everyday citizens who are just
like I'm going to find my happy ending
and and they do it over and over and
over again
um and I I just love and they actually
recreated there's a photo aerial photo
of them recreating that picture where
he's in the wheel she's in the back seat
mother-in-law's in the trunk with the
bricks and the the there's a sequel to
the story because another guy did that
same thing and it's like the windscreen
off but he rented the same car
I love it
okay we've spoken about a lot of the
brutality
there's been some small glimmers of Hope
what are the big glimmers of Hope
um
what do you what do you mean well you've
got this essentially overnight uh
full of uh death throws of this foreign
culture philosophy institution that's
being going on forever and it is brought
about by two conservatives in the US and
the UK
and a Russian yeah
and it would have been almost
Unthinkable but it was Unthinkable the
day before your man said it was
Unthinkable the day before but then it
evidently wasn't yeah if you look at
Star Trek what's his name check off yeah
the idea is
you know you had the Korean War which
was a draw you had the Vietnam War which
was a complete disaster for the west and
it was certainly not a victory for for
the West in the 70s the argument was
like all right
look sovieting is not going anywhere
they're not they're not doing great but
they're certainly not
this is this is the reality if you want
to be realistic instead of thinking
they're going anywhere we have to
realize we're going to be in a world
with two superpowers we have to make
nice with one another and understand one
another because otherwise the costs are
going to be nuclear war and world
destruction neither party wants that so
instead of saber rattling we need to sit
down and work things out because this is
going to be the status quo at least for
another even if we have warp speed even
if we have warps right even with the
Federation this is just the nature of a
reality and in before he became
president
Ronald Reagan sat down with one of his
advisors and he goes
um my policy for the Cold War is simple
and some would even say simplistic we
win they lose
and that kind of approach of
um
this is not
I'm not going to live on this Earth
where this sort of thing is going to be
normalized but the thing is Thatcher and
Reagan really weren't
interested in bringing down the Soviet
Union as their primary goal Reagan
especially his big interest was ending
the threat of nuclear war
and there's this couple of scenes that I
uncovered in the research because you
know they're playing poker you know the
US and the USSR right they both have to
act one way in public another way in
private neither wants to kill each other
neither wants to be killed like you know
this is you're playing brinksmanship and
they bring Reagan down to show him the
how you retaliate if there's a nuclear
strike and his aides thought they're
like he's not going to
do it and you he talked about this in
the sense of like wait a minute so if I
retaliate then within minutes
literally millions if not tens of
millions of Russians are who are
innocent people who whose only crime was
being born on the far side the Iron
Curtain which they can't leave and when
I retaliate I'm going to be killing all
of them and he's like I'm the president
I'm the most powerful man in the world
and I'm the good guy I'm killing in
minutes tens of millions of people like
it made no sense to him and the but the
beautiful part is Gorbachev is taken
down into the bunker
and he's throwing the rehearsal and they
go okay Mr you know General Secretary
you know if this happens this is the
button you press and he goes I'm not
pressing that button even for practice
purposes and he's like if they strike us
too bad
and but neither knew the other had this
position and what's fascinating is
Thatcher uh who is PM at the time prime
minister Great Britain she gets a lot of
heat very correctly for being a scold
she you know the first time she met
Gorbachev he came to Checkers before he
was uh out of the Soviet Union
um you know she wanted to meet him which
was it's the prime minister's like
summer house whatever they call it
something the equivalent of Camp David
here and they're coming to breakfast and
she's yelling at him about their
economics and she's yelling at him about
their foreign policy and she's yelling
him to the foreign rights and then she's
human rights and then she's yelling him
that he hasn't touched his breakfast and
Gorbachev just stops and he goes
you know I wasn't sent here to convert
you to Communism like I have my own
views so let's just take it down a notch
and she just bursts out laughing but
what she doesn't get credit for was her
sense of diplomacy because she and she
boasted about this constantly and fairly
she was the one who spotted him she said
she made him well she took credit for
him she went on the BBC and said I could
do business with Mr Gorbachev and
because both of them Reagan and Thatcher
were on the right wing of the right-wing
parties in each country that gave them
the space to be diplomatic I mean when
you think of Thatcher you think of the
opposite of diplomacy uh she you know
never had a fight she didn't like she
was always throwing hands at Prime
Minister's questions she was always
going after members her own cabinets she
called them uh a wets which in
contemporary terms is like calling
someone a soy boy these were like her
own because it's like he's all wet right
doesn't that mean in Britain yeah like
she called them that and you know she
said she did not suffer fools gladly but
they both independently sat down with
Gorbachev and they're like all right
like this situ this status quo rather
than being Perpetual is intolerable we
cannot live in this world Reagan and
Gorbachev thought this very strongly
where we have Lord knows even we don't
know how many nuclear missiles are
pointed at one another and that God
forbid you know someone gets angry or
something happens and within 20 seconds
all life on Earth is destroyed this this
can't happen and together you know they
sat down and gave Gorbachev the space to
demilitarize and the thing is when you
have these kind of regimes
and I think Gorbachev really ends up
being the hero of the book because there
were so many times when people were on
the phone with him from other countries
other communist countries and saying
General Secretary it's all going to [ __ ]
you need to send the tanks and he goes
no I'm not doing it and to me you know
people often talk about like what what's
Beauty and Beauty could be like a
beautiful woman it could be like a
sunset it could be you know a song that
there's a heart to me beauty that really
kind of gets me really in a very Primal
emotional way is when these extremely
powerful people choose to take their
hand off the trigger and are like I'm
not going to be killing people I I don't
care if it's gonna cost me personally
it's just the wrong thing to do I'm not
going to be on the side of the
executioners and there are so many
moments in this book Lithuania being a
major example where they're begging him
to use force and they're telling him
correctly if you do not Mr Gorbachev if
you do not send in the tanks like this
this system that you grew up in that
makes the Soviet Union the Rival to the
United States is all going to fall apart
and he's like too bad like it's going to
go peacefully
um and there's a great scene in East
Germany where hanukker you know who's
the dictator he's Germany's watching the
footage of these marches and he's like
all right we got to do something we need
another Tiananmen Square and the head of
the military who is no Dove no soy boy I
mean this guy has a lot of blood in his
hands a lot of aggression he goes he
basically can I can I curse he basically
says [ __ ] you we're not doing anything
this is gonna resolve peacefully and
hanukker was out of office the next day
so that's the other like white pill
moment like it's not that there are lots
of times when genuinely evil people when
people who have a lot of blood on their
hands and have done a lot of atrocities
for one reason or another maybe not
voluntarily through but because the
chips are not in their favor where
they're like okay I'm out this is my
limit and I'm I'm not going to make
things worse even if just from personal
sense of self-preservation where it's
like if I pull this trigger my bullets
in my head next so I'm gonna back away
if that's their motivation I'm fine with
it the most important but the thing is
with Gorbachev it wasn't his motivation
he genuinely was like all right he spent
enough time with the West as opposed to
other
um people who became in leadership roles
in Soviet Union where he's like he went
to
in 68 there was a kind of a softening of
Communism in Czechoslovakia there's
something called the Prague spring
dupchek who is head of Czechoslovakia
wanted to implement socialism with the
human face when Gorbachev went to visit
Czechoslovakia not long after that and
the Russians send the tanks and you know
took him out of office he went to a
factory and the factory workers
literally turned their backs on him to
just give him like a show of like like
you were you were evil and to see that
when you're like I'm just here to help
you run your factory on like this nobody
middle apparatchik and to see like we
were told in our newspapers that you
were happy that we were liberating or
saving the revolution Czechoslovakia and
then I see the workers you know and any
of these workers would pull a bullet in
me if they had their druthers that was a
very eye-opening moment for him and he's
like I don't want to be that guy and he
had the what does power mean if not the
ability to say you know what I'm not
going to use this power but could you
imagine if
instead of getting a Gorbachev you got
another Stalin well they had that I mean
Brezhnev wasn't another Stalin but the
fact that he said in a tanks in 68 in
Prague the fact that the Hungarian
rebellion in I think it was 56 uh was 13
days where the hungarians were like all
right we're leaving the Warsaw Pact and
khrushchev's like oh that's cute and he
they hung uh imrinagi who was the Prime
Minister uh you know so yeah you don't
need that's the other scary thing when
you have systems like this you don't
need another
like everyone you're it's going to be
very hard to get into Stalin's seat
without being another Stalin because
you're gonna have to get through all
these kind of filters
I've had two conversations in the last
month one with Schultz and one with
Goggins and I asked both of them I find
it interesting asking people similar
questions I like to get the the a
different response to the same prompt
and both of them have had long uh
relationships going on Joe show and
asked them both about I would what's it
like you know being friends with Rogan
and sort of observing what's been going
on so on and so forth uh and both of
them have said basically the same thing
which is kind of this very odd situation
where somebody that has the most power
is the person that's the most benevolent
with it
the person who is
giving and is prepared to use their
platform to be able to raise others up
so on and so forth and um yeah it it
seems to me like I I we're both good
friends with Michaela Michaela for the
people that don't know is named after
Gorbachev yes that's why Jordan called
her Michaela
I'm not kidding when I said
when I thought to myself
why why name your daughter after this
male Russian dude I didn't know up until
I read this book
any difference between Stalin and
barrier and
Gorbachev I do just the old Russian guys
that ran the country maybe they did some
bad things maybe they did some good
things I don't know
it kind of makes sense I didn't know
either so when I I had this weird
Western look at the end of Cold War and
I thought Reagan and Thatcher were going
to be the heroes and as I was writing it
when you write a book some of them the
characters write themselves it's very
clear he's the hero of the three of them
uh not that they didn't do heroic things
but in terms of the person who
sacrificed the most who was most
committed to peace who had the most
opportunity to turn things in a very bad
Direction he's not an angel let me be
clear but in terms of the amount of good
things and choices he made in the area
of Peace it's just off the charts so I
can very easily see now having written
the book
why he did this and I had no idea why
having previously written this book he
would have done it so you say it is
possible that those of us who fight for
the Dignity of mankind will lose our
fight it is not possible that we must
lose our fight that is the white pill
well thanks for spoiling the book Chris
I'm sorry the final line and you
revealed that it was it was Michael
malice all along yeah yeah what's that
mean
uh it means that hope doesn't mean that
nothing bad happens
hope doesn't mean you know someone once
yelled at me like how can you you're
talking about the white pill but you
moved from New York you had to you were
Jordan from New York to go to Austin I'm
like yeah I'm not saying nothing bad
ever happens I'm saying that the idea
that the good guys are these omnipotent
deities and you're completely powerless
against them and they're they're all
knowing and all-powerful and they're
always going to win it's like but that's
not true first of all no matter how evil
you think they are as I demonstrate this
book They're much worse like I didn't
realize just how evil the Soviet Union
was have until I read this book uh and
again this is the North Korea guy like
it's so much bigger and worse than I had
realized and I have all the receipts in
it but also the fact that
you don't if you as the reader don't
always get what you want why are you
seeding to them this view that they
always get what they want you know what
I mean like if I'm just use an absurd
example if I'm Stalin and I want a
dinosaur like a living dinosaur I can't
get that right because dinosaurs extinct
that's just one extreme example but
there I can't just defy laws of
Economics I can't just snap my fingers
and say okay everyone's gonna be fed I
also can't snap my fingers and say
everyone who dislikes me is going to be
identified by me I'm not going to be
able to do that either so this claim
that they can always win just because
they've got the let's first of all the
person who's got the most numbers always
wins what about the George Washington
George Washington's entire career was
retreating from the British he we won
Vietnam Vietnam right Afghanistan number
number one number two is just this kind
of premise that just because some
organization has been at it for a long
time like if you're starting out on
third base right that's a huge Advantage
does everyone who's on third base make
it home no like and you wouldn't say
that and anyone said that would be
absurd so the fact that there are again
so many examples of things that could
have gone so much worse but they didn't
and it's not because these were Angels
it's not like like you said it wasn't
like one year it's Brezhnev then Mother
Teresa comes in right it's not like
Reagan was an angel it's not like
Thatcher was an angel hardly it's not
like the people in West Berlin were all
these kind of Saints or the people in
East Berlin were all Saints or vice
versa these were human beings and human
beings as we talked earlier are finite
there's limits to our knowledge there's
limits to our abilities and at a certain
point the costs outweigh the benefits
look at the Confederacy right when Lee
surrendered there were lots of people in
the former Confederacy who were like
we're just gonna keep fighting forever
but at a certain point you have to look
at it be like all right I can't win
fight so just out of a sense of
self-preservation I'm just going to be
like all right it's a wrap and that's
what happened in many of these countries
and that is that what I think is going
to happen a certain point uh with
malevolent elements in the west that the
costs are just going to be too much for
them to bear and they're just going to
fold to claim that the foes of human
decency are uniquely Brave and valorous
to me is another just blatant one of
their lies
what do you think most people
misunderstand about evil
um
I think
there's two things one is I think
Americans in the political sense
think an evil person has a weird
mustache and is banging the desk right
they they really think it you know I
talk about this in the book where
there's this I think it was uh I forget
who wrote the poem was Leonard Cohen
about um you know one of these Nazis
height normal eyes normal hair normal
it's like what do you expect things like
people really even though even religious
people who understand that the devil is
seductive still expect the devil to be
walking in with Hooves and horns like
that that's not how you look at um who
is that the the serial killer in um uh
Florida who was played by that um
Jeffrey Dahmer no the one in Florida who
has killed all those women uh who just
looked like a um uh
we're both trust me we're both gonna
feel stupid later anyway people are
screaming it into their airport and he
was played by that actor with Zac Efron
Ted Bundy Ted Bundy Ted Bundy you
couldn't pick him out he if anything is
good looking right you just think he's
like a normal guy yeah so so people
understand that intellectually but they
don't really understand her emotionally
so that's one thing second is I don't
think people appreciate how
sophisticated evil can get when it comes
systematized
so again when we think of like political
evil we think of like again the
government brutality like the cops are
beating you up in your cell or you're
putting the solitary they are not
thinking of the evil when it comes not
to those who have been identified as
criminals but to those who who are not
criminals not even accused of criminals
and the oppression that can happen in
that regard and I don't think they
appreciate how comfortable
evil is in taking hostages
so you think you know Christopher
there's nothing you could do I'm gonna
stand up but when it's family it comes
along you're you'd fold in two seconds
and and you you turned me in and I
wouldn't blame you and I think the other
thing that was turned out it turned up
uh in that chapter of nastasi is people
in this country and I thought this as
well
we're of the belief that those who were
informants to the secret police who
snitched on their friends their
co-workers uh um their neighbors
had a gun to their head themselves so
they bring in Chris they're like all
right Chris I need 10 names and you're
like or we're gonna kill you and your
family it's like all right Michael Zach
you know blah blah what we don't realize
here in the west is a lot of these
people were volunteered
they were more than happy uh and one of
the Stasi recruiters point out we didn't
even pay them that much it's like they
just wanted to feel important or they
were bored or they just felt they were
doing the right thing and that to me is
an element of evil that Americans are
I would say almost entirely but
decreasingly oblivious too well how
would you categorize that that last was
this was the banality of evil right
maybe she's not using the term the same
way but that's kind of like how come
commonplace it is there's this there's
this one very disturbing scene in this
which I got from Anna funder
um no no I got it from Timothy Galt Nash
whose book was called the file and I
both are great Anna funder's books
called staziland I forget which is which
after East Germany fell they opened up
the Stasi files so you could go in
and you could see what information they
had on you and who turned you in and
this was a big moment for every East
German to be like do I want to know
or do I want to just look the other way
and just pretend it never happened do I
want to know what would you do
it depends on how if I went to so that's
the thing right some people had gone to
jail
some people hadn't gone to jail maybe
it's just a curiosity thing I think I
would probably I don't know I don't know
we anyone listening to this who says
they would know
it's it's think about it for a second
because would you want to know that your
brother-in-law turned you in
on the one hand you could say yes the
only hand you could say no right it's
it's not that simple and the story in
the book there's a woman whose job there
um Frau trampleman I think her name is
and the line the author has is how do
you work with Poison every day and not
become poisoned yourself her job when
the people come in is to sit them down
and be and basically walk them through
it's kind of like how they used to have
if you take an AIDS test you have to
physically go to the doctor to get the
results so he can be there to kind of
walk you through if it's positive so
you're not by yourself at home like with
a gun to your head
and this woman came in and she had been
in jail for I think four or five years
because she had wanted to like leave
East Germany and she found out through
reading her file that it was the guy
she's still living with
that's just lost it
and he that morning he told her have a
nice day how do you go home to that and
this is an entire country of people like
this you know so
um it's it's
you know those of us who say they'd
rather know
I I
uh maybe I can see the case for both
sides very easily
like would you want to know ask
yourselves if you're one of your parents
passed away
and you learned that they were
um being unfaithful to your other parent
their entire lives is that something
you'd want to know or is that something
where you're like they're dead I don't
I'd rather remember them as my dad or my
mom than as someone who couldn't keep in
their pants as opposed to a ton of
resentment for no reason yeah
you
have a quote where you say you should
take one red pill and not the whole
bottle yeah
what's the appropriate dosage of white
pills
[Laughter]
it's one block at White pillbook.com
that's good enough for me dude I am I
can credit you with opening up an awful
lot of my understanding around this sort
of middle 1900 uh depths of human
depravity uh Heights of human hope
complicity of uh journalists and uh
State enforcements uh in in hiding awful
and
disgusting actions both within their own
country and and outside of it I have had
a serious historical education uh from
reading this and also uh you write
beautifully like it's so
the the pacing the way that you use your
sentences it's the same way that you
speak a really really genuinely
genuinely enjoyed it there was a bunch
of things like the uh just a little
passage about um
Lenin who is widely regarded as a
lunatic like just the way that it's done
it's the same way that you would speak
it and I I very very much enjoyed it
especially given that I had no uh
background to it so dude uh
congratulations you know I talked to you
we were close friends throughout the
whole process of writing this book and I
talked to you a lot about how it was
really getting to me and how intense and
emotional constantly why these stories
were both in negative sense and the
positive sense like like the Hans
meizner who drove the Speedster under
the thing uh just so much darkness and
so much Beauty
um and I I'm glad that you can see what
I was going through
um for the last couple of years and and
I think to me this was almost more like
an exorcism
because there were just so many um
uh like Souls just and now to have the
idea that they would just be forgotten
and and for stories swapped in the rug
and I'm like I'm gonna do something
about this these people need to be
valorized and remember and be remembered
just so many just innocent you know
victims who just happen to be wrong be
born in the wrong place at the wrong
time or looked at somebody the wrong way
um so I I'm just so glad that I was I'm
in an opportunity to uh um
keep their memory uh you did a
commendable job on him if it was I think
that they would all be incredibly
grateful what you've done
how many references are there in this
book I didn't actually in fact I can get
it as a 500. I can get it up right now
and find out because you do you've done
it in Roman numerals right in the way
that the references in the Kindle I
think it's Roman numerals in the in the
hard cover it's it's numbers okay so I
haven't ever seen Roman numerals go up
this High I didn't know that what's this
so what page am I on here this is Page
341 yeah LD e x x v i
l
LDL is is an L 500 [ __ ] knows I don't
know but if I go all the way to the very
very end oh and it doesn't even tell me
it's still in Roman numeral it's still
in [ __ ] Roman numerals all the way to
the end so I don't know lots though uh
my point being that you've done a [ __ ]
ton of research and it's incredibly
impressive
um you know looking at the stuff that
you've got this from like where it's
come from [ __ ] from the 1800s random
back catalog uh dude it's very very
impressive especially given that I'm
starting my journey of writing at the
moment and observing somebody that is
you know I mean this is Mastery I think
but I I mean this is I'm not saying this
to be glib this isn't my first rodeo and
I
can't believe I pulled it off it took me
over two years and if this was my first
book I don't know that I'd be able to do
it like at all because I'm trying to do
your first bench session with 600 pounds
well it's I think it's honestly it's
like trying to do a bench in a squad at
the same time no no and I'll tell you
why no no I'll tell you why it's a good
metaphor because first of all to even
condense this much history into a book
is just almost impossible because it
kept growing right right and it's this
under 400 pages so to keep it to numbers
is is right but then also to have it
just the writing alone to have history
being written in a conversational tone
is almost impossible most history books
are dry as hell and I wanted to make
sure there's something that is readable
and also on a personal level you know
when I I've mentioned this when I was on
on Dave Smith When I Was co-authoring
books of celebrities it's kind of like
method acting right you want to get into
their head as much as possible and
that's something that I've taken with me
whenever I write my own books but when
I'm getting into the head of you know
these people who are being brutalized or
just that woman you know even that was
that section was just copy and paste but
just thinking about what that's like to
go in and find out that your roommate or
boyfriend it's not really clear turned
you in and you're still living with this
person I mean it does a number on you
and it would do a number in anybody
are you glad that you're done
I am
um
I'm right now in a very surreal space in
a positive way
because it's so there were some issues
with the publication when it came out uh
and the first there's no hard copy is
available at the moment is that right it
just takes like two weeks but they're
available
um
there was an issue with the pricing on
the first day and I was like uh uh and
if it had gone through mainstream
publisher that would have just been
forever wash so it took a while for
people to get their copies of the book
and so I have the launch I do I did Lex
Friedman's show and then it's kind of
like radio silence right because I'd
been working for so long and I was like
holy crap it's DOA
and I had to talk to our buddy Blair
Blair white God bless her and she's like
you've been so
um trained by social media to have
instant feedback
that if you're not getting results like
that first day like you think it's done
and she's like this is people haven't
gotten their copies how are they going
to be responding to it and that kind of
clicked but that kind of worked for a
bit but now that these responses are
coming in there was a book that was
published about how Reagan won the Cold
War by Dutton which is a mainstream
publisher I just found this out this
morning Wall Street Journal called her
on the books of the Year Amazon had as a
staff pick I'm not selling him like
three to one
um it's just and doing I haven't even
started my podcast roll out so the fact
that it's selling so well so quickly and
getting responses from so many names
because this I know this always sounds
like humble bragging but I really
this is such an important story to me
and because this is my Heritage you know
you were just certain age you kind of
looked back where you came from the fact
that I'm in my own best I can doing
Justice to some many people in so many
countries for so long and making sure
you know there's that line in The Iron
Lady you know where it's the young
Margaret Roberts is just yelling at
Dennis one's life must matter but like
you know to be able to sit there and be
like this is being forgotten and I'm and
to be able to do something about it and
seeing that what I wanted to do about it
is getting done it's almost
like being in a dream like to be able to
change reality to have that power it's
just I'm very very blessed
unreal man I'm proud of you thank you
very much that means a lot thank you for
being here at whitepoolbook.com Michael
malice on Twitter
I apologize for my Twitter I apologies
in advance That's it man thank you thank
you what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
thank you
[Music]